me
[音楽]
こんばんは8人になりましたニュースをお伝えします
きょう未明静岡市在住の自称動画クリエイター肇社長の巨大なグミを食べるだけの
しょうもない動画が再生回数1億回を突破した疑いがあることが分かりました
wh
ご覧いただいているこの映像は2015年7月に枝容疑者が実際に投稿した動画です
このしょうもない動画は去年12月ごろから世界各地で再生回数が激増したとみられ
現在も再生回数が伸びている模様です
この状況に対し江田容疑者はえなんでと話しています
ミュージックビデオ以外の youtube 動画で1億回再生突破は静岡県内で初
ユーチューバーのしょうもない動画としては日本初の記録とみられています
統計によりますとこの動画が最も再生された日は去年
2018年12月15日で1日で10018万回再生されたということです
この記録は動画の公開日からおよそ2年3ヵ月ぶりの快挙になります
これに対し江田容疑者は今更すぎんと話しています
またこのへんなグミを食べるだけのしょうもない動画の再生地域を見てみると
日本以外のインドベトナムブラジルインドネシアなど暑いイメージのある地域でさん
まり以上の再生回数を占めています
この結果を受けて一部の関係者からは肇社長がインド人ではないかと国籍詐称を指摘
する声が上がり
これに対して枝容疑者は日本人だわと容疑を否認しているということです
番組では容疑者が1億回再生を突破した瞬間の貴重な映像を独占入手しました
ただだからねっ
ご覧いただいている映像は今朝6時ごろ静岡市内にある容疑者の自宅にて撮影された
映像です
事件当時容疑者は熟睡しており意識がなく
記念すべき瞬間に立ち会えなくて残念だったと供述しています
さあそしてここで速報が入ってきましたたった今
容疑者の肇社長が現場に現れたようです
中継がつながっています現場の田中さん
はいこちら中継の田中です
容疑者の肇社長と中継がつながっております
お願いします
源さんまずは再生回数1億回トッパーおめでとうございません
もうつながっているか
はい
ありがとうござい
続いてなんですけれどもあの1億回突破した瞬間の気持ち
いかがだったでしょうか
さあ飛んする下がってます
ねえ家
あっ
そうですねはい
いやーもう
んな動画で1兆回行く
と思ってなかったトリックしましたそしてですね最後に今後の目標について聞かせて
ください
5なってますね
今後の向きをそうですねまぁ一応9回今回行ったんですけども
この動画だけって思わず次の動画
別の道ですねいっちょ9回
行ったりそういうの2本3本ってたくさん今後
出せていければいいなと思ってますありがとうございます最後にですねあの
もう一つだけあの一さん一部関係者からですね
肇社長はインド人だったんではないかと恐れ声が上がっているんですが実際のところ
どうなんでしょ
インド人じゃねーわ
me
ええええええ
立っ